hey guys welcome back to City skylines
today the main thing which I'll be
working on is this rest area over here
and that'll take quite a while though
not that long another thing which I'll
be working on in this episode is another
interchange which I'm actually really
happy with how it came out in the end
and there's also a bit of adding some
farm fields I did cut out some of the
field making process since it's really
most of the the most time-consuming
thing that I was working on at this
point in time and really what's most of
my gameplay turned out to be and it's a
bit boring and repetitive to actually
get into it but I still want to keep
some of it in the videos but it's by far
the biggest amount of work I should also
say about this video that I didn't
really prepare the commentary as much as
I usually do in any case I don't think I
ever talks about this in any video but I
usually make like a topic list of stuff
that I can talk about in the video and
things I want to mention but I sort of
don't have that much time at the moment
so I'm just doing this in one go and I
only very quickly check the video for
what's actually happening so I'm sure
I'll manage somehow
but it's I don't know it might not be as
good as it usually is or as I would like
to make it anyway to talk about the rest
area for a second here it's a very
general rest area I didn't really
particularly base it on any real one
though I did find out a couple people
told me that it looks very similar to
one which exists on the border between
Belgium and the Netherlands nail it down
which it actually turns out to be very
similar to but it isn't really based on
any specific one I just wanted to make
sure I got the petrol station in there
and in this case I just wanted to use a
double one and have them slightly
overlap to make it seem like it's one
building because you really find that
these highway rest area tank petrol
stations are just much larger than the
inner city and small road ones that you
find which I couldn't really find a
large petrol station at least not at the
time I'm not sure if they really exist
at the moment but I figured that was the
best way to overcome that problem I also
wanted to have a number of small
restaurants some fast food chains over
here
and of course the parking spots for all
of the truck drivers and one that's also
one of the reasons or some of the
reasons why I wanted to have this here I
didn't really have many highway services
yet in the city and along the city
itself the highway is very compact and
there isn't much space left so I
definitely couldn't do it there and you
do find these rest areas quite commonly
in the middle of these portals with not
too many towns very close by so I
figured this would be a pretty good area
to at least place it even if it doesn't
work out that well within the city it's
definitely good practice because it's
something that I would like to add to
all of my highways at least at certain
points because you realistically can't
go without these things at least not
every once in a while there is still a
couple of other things about the realism
aspect of highways like actually having
barriers on the or guardrails on the
side of the road
which is something I wish I could do and
I do have some guardrail objects but it
would just take such a massive amount of
time to actually do it so I don't think
I'll go into that but just having a rest
area seem like a fun thing to do and a
good way to get at least a bit of extra
realism in there and a good practice for
any type of other highway services like
the very small rest areas with without
any big restaurants or any petrol
stations but you know just the general
parking places it's also something that
I might want to get into in the future
and at least it's good practice for now
the other side of this while this thing
basically is going to just mirror the
other side as well it's a little bit
more compact since I did have that
little road on the other side there and
I think I just got one restaurant in on
this side and just added the bridge in
between them as you commonly see to make
sure that you know you can still visit
the restaurants on the other side and
don't have to place two of the same
restaurants on both sides aside from
that though yeah it's a it's a very
standard rest area speaking of the dike
though I made a pretty bad mistake over
there and that is that I actually like
broke up the dikes
just to make room for the highway which
makes no sense because the dykes are too
father of one certain polo and make sure
that it doesn't flood and stay all the
water stays within that port and it's
very strange to actually cut through a
dike with a highway and should at least
go over it so that's a pretty dumb
mistake then I might need to correct at
some point in the future another thing
which I feel I really have to nitpick
and I just really want to nitpick on my
own work in general is that I wouldn't
really call it work I'm just playing a
game but it's it's like these park these
parking lots just oh now it's much
larger than they really should have been
which was really the issue of placing
the parking lots before I place the
trucks because I had an idea that the
trucks were a little bit larger than
this so I was placing down the parking
spots being like well this is probably
going to be a pretty good size and fit
very neatly and then the trucks turn out
to be quite a lot smaller in scale than
I actually thought they were so that
doesn't work out too well so yeah
definitely there is a lot more room on
the parking spaces another issue there
is that I can't realistically use these
same asphalt as the road for the parking
spaces just because you don't have
parking spaces that work like this in
the game which makes it a little less
realistic because obviously you wouldn't
have parking spaces on the pavement like
you're pretty much forced to do and I
would just love to have it on a sports
but that's just a nitpick I can't really
do much about aside from that though I
do get some comments about the fact that
I always criticize my own stuff in
videos it's not to say that I think it's
completely bad and I still love making
these videos and really the in-game
recording most of all things but it's
just I don't want to not criticize
myself because there's always something
to improve and I really do feel like if
you if you can't criticize yourself you
can't really improve the best way to
improve at least is to basically tell
yourself that your own stuff is [ __ ] so
yeah that's the idea behind that and
aside from that I just wanted to dress
this area up a little bit not going to
in depth in that but I did want to add
some simple foliage here in there
and some very small objects and also
have a couple of houses a few small
farms over here though definitely not
anything too spectacular perhaps one of
the issues that I could throw up is that
this canal over here and I'm not
entirely sure how I should fix it at
some point in the future I definitely
don't think keys will do the job because
it's much more realistic to just have
grocery wars on the side of a canal in
the Netherlands but it's it's a canal
which generally looks quite unrealistic
it came with the map and it actually
went on in a straight curve much longer
than it currently does I did go back and
I believe it was off-screen changed the
canal since it was pretty much is 100%
straight and the same guy was going for
the highway next to it and that was
really just extremely unrealistic but
it's still very large wide straight
canal which is something which you don't
really see at least not looking like
this anyway I also wanted to have a
small town next to this area I do want
to make it a little bit larger in the
future I mean in this episode I'll
already add some farms and fields around
this town but in the future I do want to
make it a little bit bigger with just a
smaller newer neighborhood with row
houses as well since at the moment it's
basically just a pretty standard town
with just some random houses but no
really newer developments and no row
houses in a sense that I feel I could
add to just to make it a little bit
bulkier of a town I don't know it just
really seemed like the type of place
where I wanted to have a small town like
this and the rest of the area though is
still going to be pretty sparsely
populated and just be a pretty big
number of Potter's with just farming
fields and things like that which is
definitely going to be by far the
majority of this part of the map and
partly I do like it but it is definitely
going to be quite repetitive in terms of
making the videos since there's a lot of
this part making stuff hence why I did
want to cut out some of it in this video
but I think it's also a good time to
talk about the future of the city
because truth be told I'm not entirely
sure about the future of the city so we
keep in mind is that this episode is
recorded quite a while ago I don't
exactly remember how much time it was
but it's approximately three weeks I
think so it's quite a long time ago it's
actually more than three weeks easily
more than three weeks just over four
weeks I think and I am commentating this
actually just before it's uploaded so I
do sort of have the newest updates and
part of the game in mind speaking of
that it might actually be five weeks
perhaps even more I'm not entirely sure
anymore but yeah this was recorded just
before the key updates that's basically
something which I'm trying to say I'm
not entirely sure how much time that was
ago but it's basically that this was
recorded at a time when the game was
still different than what it is right
now but I'm commentating over this with
knowing what we have at the moment which
is why it doesn't feel very synchronized
in that way because there are certain
things where I even look back and think
I could have changed certain things and
the reason why I want to talk about this
is that even though I said that I would
sort of take this city to the end I've I
feel like there's been a point now where
it's it feels like it's a bit outdated
there are new houses which some people
have made even some people have uploaded
or at least actually commented on my
videos if I would like to see more Dutch
houses and actually got some replies and
some such houses in the workshop just
because of that which is really awesome
but I feel like this city is in general
just becoming outdated not just in terms
of like having new content but also I've
just gotten better at making things
while recording this city and I've
gotten more than double the amount of
hours in City skylines since I started
recording this which is also counting
all the countless hours that I didn't
record for this specific city or that I
recorded for the city but off screen so
I feel like this is a point where I
might actually
you know call this series and end at
least without it being 100% completely
finished and filling the map as I
originally intended to because it also
turned out to be quite taking quite much
longer than actually than I expected to
take for this and the reason why is
because and I've thought about this
quite a lot but I think I'd rather start
something new then just stay stuck in
this city just for the hell of finishing
this because even though this might look
really awesome and things finished I
think it might be better to try some
some projects which are smaller in scale
try different types of cities because I
have so many ideas for different types
of cities that I want to try but sort of
don't really get to because this series
is more or less holding me back in that
way so yeah basically I feel like I
might want to step into new territory
and I may make a new Dutch city at some
point in the future
there are also some plans that I have
for an alpine city or perhaps a planned
economic city much like the one in
Tunisia or a city like Qatar but those
are just ideas that I want to play with
and the reasons why I might and this
series in I'm not entirely sure how many
episodes but just wrap it up at some
point soon in the future so yeah just so
you know there are definitely some other
plans that I have and that's do
something which I felt I really wanted
to talk about anyway I also wanted to
have this into the intersection over
here which is I think really my favorite
intersection of the city so far it's a
combination of diamonds and a cloverleaf
just to have this little regional road
connects to all the farms and the
smaller towns which I want to have in
the future with the highway over here
and it's actually gonna be a somewhat
important road in the future because
even though it won't take that much
traffic at the moment
it'll take a quite a lot actually at
some point in the future because I
basically want to extend this area into
what is now the upper part of the screen
where I want to add lots of stuff up as
well but not so much the
Porter's and simple forms that I have in
this area but I want to try to make a
new town with some new stuff just to
experiment with new ideas so there will
actually be a small camping with
caravans and stuff like that and some
small chalets as well in that part of
the city or that part of the region I
should probably say and it's also where
at some points though this is going to
be a bit further away I think I'll try
to add some flower fields in a very
inefficient way even though there are
flower fields on the workshop I wanted
to make flower fields myself just get
the colors and shapes entirely right
which turn out to be quite a
time-consuming thing but actually
something which is pretty cool though
looking back at it in future reference I
may want to use some flower fields
instead and just get that over with
pretty quickly and at some point in the
future though that is way further in the
future I'll work on the theme park in
that area and that's something which I
most recently recorded and something
which I am really looking forward to
show which is it something which
turnouts better really I think in
hindsight than I expected and really
feels like coming home almost the thing
that I'm most used to and which is
actually surprisingly well possible in
this game but yeah that is just
everything about the future as I was
filling in these forms over here just to
make sure that that was all alright I
think I'll get to the foliage at
something in the future just off screen
especially adding all the different
three lines is going to get pretty
boring pretty quickly and I'm even glad
that I've been using the resources as
the Terra painting just to make this
look like farms because as much as I do
like the assets that are out there to
have textures for farms on your farm
fields it's just something that is way
less user-friendly since it would take
even more time than what it currently
does and it's also something which is
just less flexible in terms of shapes
and such and I liked the wheat fields
with the little round wheat crops which
you can basically place a lot of in one
field to make a wheat field kind of
thing
but it's also very time-consuming and
pretty painful and performance as well
and something which I don't really feel
the need for too much it's just that
this general area is made to make the
more important parts feel like that
actually situated in Holland so this
isn't really the focus of the city it's
just that I want to have these porters
around the cities and the more
interesting parts of this entire area to
make it feel like it's actually in a
realistic setting and not have it be
located in the middle of an empty
grassland because I'm not sure if I
really set this before I may have well
done that but I always forget what I say
in videos and what I say in streams but
one of my issues still with this game is
that even if you're starting out on the
new map you start out in a completely
new map like you're in some sort of
uninhabited space with just a railway
and a highway and it would just be
really cool to start out with an already
sort of developed map and have some
farms here and there but actually also
some small towns as you realistically
see when you'd start out having a city
like you really starts in the middle of
nowhere which is just not a realistic
thing simulation wise and it makes it a
very time-consuming thing to actually
make the realistic surroundings of a
city which is just a personal preference
really I do think there's it's it's
pretty common complaints though really
about this type of game and I definitely
get why they wouldn't add it since it
just makes things so much more
complicated but it is something that's I
kind of lack in the game at the moment
and just one of the reasons why I want
to spend so much time myself getting all
these fields and areas around the cities
and even though I don't really care
about it too much and I won't have any
like close-up shots of these fields just
for the hell of it though it is still
kind of fun to make them or at least
surprisingly not boring I would say it's
just there as a general backdrop of the
bigger parts and the city itself really
and this is also the type of thing that
I would just like to get into more if at
some point in a few
and it's gonna be at some soon point in
the future I decide to just leave the
city as it is at the moment and just
leave it as a really good learning
experience and as a lot of fun but move
on to certain things the last thing I
would like to do is to wrap it up is not
add any new things or add a new city
district or actually even get into a
harbor I think that's not even that
well-planned in this city but I just
want to have some quick fields just
around the areas which I have at the
moment to make them seem like they're
situated in a realistic touch setting or
really yeah at least try to do so and
just really leave it there because as
much as I have had fun making this city
and I'll still have a couple of episodes
it's definitely not the end of the
series quite yet I just feel like it's
might start to hold me back and as soon
as it I feel like it's holding me back
I'd rather just start something
completely new perhaps leave the city a
little bit unfinished but it's mostly
just been fun and a good learning
experience and I can still probably get
some pretty good shots in of what I have
at the moment it's just that I want to
broaden my horizon a bit more I guess
perhaps it's also the fact that at this
point it's almost become a sort of
routine and I've gone into the way that
these fields are just made and the parts
of the city are made and I feel like it
would either be a good choice to move on
and try some completely different things
and get to the more experimental side of
playing this game again or perhaps build
another Dutch city and completely
rebuild it and plan it out a bit more to
actually make something very realistic
as an aim and just make something which
is more ambitious than the city really
is because to get back to actually
criticizing my own thing there are a
number of problems with the city which I
have of which the first one is really
that the first couple of neighbourhoods
are just not good and that's pretty much
plain and simple that's I think the
cauliflower neighborhood too is pretty
bad it was already made in the area in
the time when I was not having too
high ambitions with this thing and just
figured I would just put a random series
on YouTube and see what the hell it
happened to it and thinking that nobody
would watch it anyway and then suddenly
this series actually got or following
which is really cool but I like started
this out and recorded the first couple
of episodes with just a very casual
approach to stuff and I didn't really
put as much thoughts or planning or even
knowledge by looking certain stuff up as
I do now so I really feel like if I
start over I can do something much more
ambitious and actually make something
more realistic but yeah those are not
problems I'm strictly of the city so
yeah but the problem is that I feel the
first neighborhoods aren't realistic the
setting is an issue because the like the
start Ford Center is something that came
in its current location in the game and
I've talked about this before but it
just doesn't really seem to have the
best location for the entire map or at
least not the most logical location of
you compared to other ones I would have
liked to see it a little bit more closer
to the river as well as that smaller
River which entrance enters into it and
the general area around the star fort
was also not well planned by me myself
so it has a very sort of weird grassy
limbo between the star fort city center
and the rest of the city which doesn't
quite feel like there are two separate
cities but it also doesn't quite feel
like it really connects well because
even though that the star wars in real
life are also quite disconnected from
the city to which they belong to it
doesn't quite feel as uncertain of how
they should really connect as it does in
this city and of course as I've said
before as well there are just so many
new things which have come out since
that time that can make whatever touch
city you're working on Willy looks so
much more realistic and it doesn't just
come from the game itself like keys and
things like that are definitely very
useful and the same goes for a theme I
would love to get into a new theme and
actually get just proper across and
gross only to be able to get grassy
slopes and cross alongside roads and
things like that but also really I want
to give the con
sends a place and any of the newer
content if I would completely build
cities out of these different houses and
these newer Dutch houses in this same
map I feel would just break the
immersion because it they look
completely different and this was almost
made in a different part of the game
which is which comes with a game which
is currently modeled and updated
definitely but yeah that's why I feel
maybe this series had too high ambitions
and just drags on a little bit too long
and I think that perhaps the best way to
word it and maybe I should stop it from
dragging on that's basically the idea
but yeah that said it's not the end for
this yet and I've still got some
episodes to burn through and I still
need to get back into this city and it
actually still works so we don't have to
worry about that I was a very worried
after the lost lost updates and it
didn't work for a couple of days really
but it's been working out and I haven't
got the prop anarchy issue I think so
that should be fine and I'll wrap it up
at some point in the future and that may
very well be a very soon point in the
future but in the meantime I would also
like I would actually also love to try
some new stuff and experiment with new
ideas and themes that I really want to
give a try and yeah that's basically all
the story about that so I'm sorry this
turned into a general update video just
because I had all of this farm footage
to sort of talk over in which not much
else happened and I think it's just sort
of important to talk about the states of
this series in general so yeah if you
manage to get through all of that time
and not be bored to death thank you very
much for watching and I'll see you guys
next time in which I'll be right a
second let me look up what I'm gonna do
next time oh yeah next time I'll be
working on the new town which is really
one of my favorite parts of the city
really so hope to see you then